information from the U.S leaks has
spread fast around the world and even to
the streets of Burkina faso's Capital
wagadugu they referred to burkina's
possible links to the Russian mercenary
Force Wagner group
Burkina Faso is a free and independent
country it can choose to cooperate with
whoever it wants to
Al Jazeera has gained access to the
documents first reported by British
media outlet turdis they say the Russian
private military company Wagner could
use its presence in Mali and Burkina
Faso to destabilize Ivory Coast
according to communication intercepted
from an ivorian security official it's
no surprise you know they Wagner has had
a voice
in Burkina fasas for for well over a
year there was some open source
reporting yesterday about a possible
camp in Burkina Faso but we're hearing
it was between 15 to 50 people so it's a
relatively small presence
we met Russian fighters from the Wagner
group in 2018 in the Central African
Republic their operations have since
spread from Mozambique Sudan to Mali and
now Burkina Faso
the two countries used to rely on their
former colonial power France to help
them fight arm groups linked to isil and
Al-Qaeda but that military cooperation
was brought to an end after the Russian
forces arrived what Wagner is doing in
Africa is an extension of moscow's
policy in the region
established a foothold for for Russia
displace the influence of the West
Burkina faso's military Junta says it
has lost control of 40 percent of the
national territory two armed groups on
National Television a mass mobilization
has been announced the Jinta can now
seize citizens vehicles and properties
it can also summon men and women above
the age of 18 to fight on the front line
salute
I salute the measure because the fight
against terrorism is one that concerns
us all and we are all suffering the
consequences and this Victory to come
will profit the entire nation
the U.S intelligence leaks suggests
Burkina may have the support of Russian
Fighters but countries neighboring this
hell are worried about Wagner's presence
and any instability it might bring
Nicholas Hawk Al Jazeera